all right let's go you have a warm
Pennsylvania welcome to a Republican
Senate candidate Dr Mehmet Oz
thank you
God bless you
thank you very much
great to see you how are you I'm doing
wonderfully while you can see the
enthusiasm in Pennsylvania the the
shocking reality uh the stark contrast
between me and John fetterman has for
for six months since I've been in
general campaign amazed most people when
they finally get it but it takes a while
for people to understand it because
there's so many ads being played by the
Democratic party creating a caricature
of who he is because what you just
described is very accurate a lot of
people didn't realize it and all of a
sudden over the last few weeks more and
more pennsylvanians are doing their
homework smart people and I trust them
to make the right choice and they're
realizing who he is and what we stand
for and I've made this comment to a lot
of folks
my father grew up on a George floor he
came to this country as an immigrant we
didn't have a lot but that did well he
believed in the land of opportunity
which is what we are and for him and our
family the embodiment of the American
Dream came true because we believed in
the Ingenuity of Americans we believed
in the grit of Americans we believe in
America that is the fundamental
difference between me and the far left
radical elements of the democratic party
and I think Sean is not the general
Democratic party because there are a lot
of conservative Democrats in
Pennsylvania who are going to vote for
me but The Fringe elements and I didn't
realize to be running against the poster
child of that movement John fetterman
but when they don't actually believe in
our ability to get things done they
start to adopt policies that don't make
any sense you've touched on a couple of
them but they start getting the wrong on
crime York Pennsylvania is halfway
between Baltimore and Philadelphia
there's a lot of crime here people here
began figuring it out clergy work with
police and they worked out some problems
and the community got involved and they
began to get in Solutions it's actually
a pretty good result compared to for
example Philadelphia which has the
highest murder rate Ever In Our Lifetime
you touched on it but you try to walk
through Philadelphia families don't let
their kids go outside stores change or
leaving the economic impact is massive
and it's not safe and those scars cause
all kinds of problems for kids that will
last for Generations they have the same
degree of post-traumatic stress disorder
and I'll speak to as a doctor as if as
some of the gis in war zones like
refugee camps that's
the big city Philadelphia Pittsburgh
where I was at the Steelers game on
Sunday tailgating just a few blocks from
where three people were murdered so
they're not immune all the cities are
experiencing this but when John
fetterman says the things that you
recounted which are absolutely accurate
is the most pro-murder con you know
candidate in America yeah that causes
problems it seems to get people a little
riled up for good reason that's why the
police when they endorsed me Sean it
wasn't just a nice play endorsement it
was unanimous you know what it's like
getting 500 cops together in a big room
they're all leaders they don't do
anything unanimously but they were so
upset as how he has been dismissive of
their efforts to do their jobs
I I have a hard time understanding I've
never I've been doing this work since
1987 when I started my radio Journey
I've never met a guy that was more
pro-convicted murderer than John
Federman I never met a guy that wanted
to open up and unleash the prison
population on their state the way he
does it's it's mind-numbing to me well
it goes beyond that the attitude is one
of this disdain like it doesn't matter
what you guys do I've got better ideas
think of this if a jury of your peers
think that you murdered somebody and a
judge sentences you to life in prison
they're probably right
and so who are you to walk in there and
say I don't care what you guys think he
seems to care more about the criminals
than the innocent and that's what I'm
hearing especially in some of the urban
populations people in Philadelphia will
say we think we're part of a social
experiment they literally are doing
things never done before to see how it
works out and we don't want to be part
of the Growing Pains of working that
through and Sean that's just on on True
Crime then there's Fentanyl and
Pennsylvania has become Ground Zero for
fentanyl deaths we're number three in
the nation we have the largest open-air
drug Market in Philadelphia you go for
blocks and blocks only see addicts with
needles sticking out of their bodies and
we're farming homelessness literally
Democratic policies have resulted in
something that's shameful they won't go
there I go there because I want to show
that Republicans care about everybody
and I think our party has a big enough
tent and we love people wherever they
are in their Journey that we can help
people in addiction and that's where
we're going to win
if I would have picked the top issues on
on the in the election this year and
this is for every state every race it is
number one 41 year high of inflation
record high gas prices wide open borders
Law and Order safety security how do you
how do you pursue happiness if you don't
have basic Safety and Security
reinforced by Law and Order he can and
then of course woke education I think
parents need want to take back their
schools and they don't want their kids
going to school and getting
indoctrinated they want uh Reading
Writing Math Science History computers
and get rid of all the other values and
let the parents instill those values at
home I think in the federal government
you're absolutely right
we have an obligation an obligation to
make sure that kids who are at risk get
educated it's better for their families
for their communities it makes the
entire country hum like a well-oiled
machine and yet we haven't been doing
that states are doing it in different
ways but it's not working in
Philadelphia 30 of the kids in third
grade read at grade level think about
that a third of the kids in third grade
are reading at the right light level the
other two thirds can't read so they're
never going to catch up we should take
taxpayer money that you decide to give
to this process make a fund at the
federal level give it back to the States
and say give that to parents who want
their kids to be able to go to parochial
schools
are the issues I mentioned
are they the issues you hear hearing
about the most and I probably would say
in the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania you
have to add energy to that list
there's no question why this race is now
neck and neck I focused on the issues
you mentioned especially the economy
crime and the border with drugs yes but
gas is part of to me the economy because
if you really want to drop inflation and
it's a much less painful way than
raising interest rates allow natural gas
to be Unleashed in Pennsylvania Tom
Cotton was coming out
Tom Cotton and I were on wellheads just
to look at this but when you say that
fracking is a stain on Pennsylvania
which John fetterman did and you showed
videos of him saying what he actually
believes that's insulting to people who
are making their living that area it
actually destroys communities and we
drive up inflation because energy drives
one third of the of the total inflation
that we see but maybe for most of us the
most important reality is it makes us
subservient to our enemies if you want
energy Independence and energy dominance
then get a natural gas out of
Pennsylvania and this is the big story
if you truly love the environment if you
really love the environment you should
root for natural gas because that's how
we've dropped our carbon footprint the
last 15 years by the way they're
predicting they're predicting gas prices
natural gas prices are going to go up
dramatically and that they may actually
lose the electric grid in New England as
a result of the shortage of natural gas
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else